the rise in hate crimes across the
country is growing a new report from the
fbi shows incidents up in 2020 13 more
than the year before matt kimbrough
joins us now in studio with more on how
the las vegas community is reacting to
this report
brian the fbi released its 2020 report
tonight now it shows that hate crimes
against african americans rose nearly 46
percent from 2019 and attacks on asian
americans grew by 73 percent we should
point out that while these numbers are
troubling many incidents don't even get
reported
no one should ever accept that hate
crimes are a part of life the fbi just
released updated numbers showing that
2020 saw the highest number of reported
hate crimes in two decades in total
nearly 62 percent of hate crimes
nationwide were tied to an individual's
race in nevada 113 incidents were
reported in 2020 compared to 47 in 2019
it's never a sign of weakness to say we
have a problem
it's a sign of weakness to ignore it
this past july a tick-tock video
surfaced of a woman at the shops at
crystals on the las vegas strip sounding
off in a racist rant making anti-asian
comments las vegas local rosita lee who
is part of the asian-american pacific
islander community says the lack of
progression we've made in these last
couple years is maddening as she has met
several people who don't come forward
after becoming victims of hate people
are
not reporting
we have found that many incidences
especially among the nurses i don't know
if you're aware but many of the nurses
are asians and there have been some
people
some patients who have said i don't want
you to treat me i want somebody else
now as we mentioned the report shows
more than half of victims in 2020 were
targeted because of their race 20
percent of people were victimized for
sexual orientation and 13 percent
because of religion back to you brian